good afternoon everyone
welcome to another enthralling episode
of coffee and commerce
gary vaynerchuk i haven't shaved to
being so
i'm trying to try to keep up with you i
know we have a bunch of questions this
week which i'm excited about so
why don't you tell everybody about the
format this week let's do them uh so
this week what we're going to do is
we're going to bring a bunch of uh
individuals who ask questions for us uh
ask us questions on twitter we're gonna
bring them live
we're gonna answer their questions and
go through it's an interactive episode
for you hope you get a lot of value out
of it
uh and without further ado let's do it
dustin let's bring our first guest on
hey gary how are you i'm very well how
are you
doing well um my name is matt i'm 17
looking to get into e-commerce
uh my first question is is there such
thing as a
two saturated e-commerce niche
um sorry it's like a two-part question
and like how does a brand differentiate
itself like from other brands to build
uh
social proof and drive conversions to um
like how does one differentiate
understanding from your competiting
brands
first of all you need to say hi to zubin
too because he got he's very upset when
people just say hi to me
sorry how how are you saying about that
what's up matt what's going on
i mean you want to take you want to take
us i'll answer the first one and you
jump on the second one
matt there there's never an
oversaturated market
there's always the right time to be the
best at something
like at any moment i mean you bro
you don't understand because you're a
youngster how legit
yahoo search engine was it was just like
google
but actually you know what's so funny i
literally thought about this the other
day i'm like
huh i wonder if google
should be disrupted like it's been so
long like why can't like
moly moly just come out and be the best
search engine of all time
the other one i've been thinking a ton
about is
twitter you know between facebook
that instagram you know tick tock like
you know linkedin it's all feed pictures
words
but the only words only for the most
part or
quick or real time is twitter i think
both
google search engine and twitter
are companies that are potentially
disruptable
over the next decade if two if somebody
comes along and does something
incredible
so if i believe that about twitter and
google the hell do you think about
what i think about an e-commerce
category like t-shirts or hats or
cannabis or whatever zoom
yeah totally the other part of it is
matt too like talk about niche right you
talk about a very specific niche if this
was back in the day 10 years ago 15
years ago you lived in a specific town
you'd be like are there enough people in
this town that i can sell this niche
product to
the reality is to gary's point first of
all there's a
millions of consumers buying online ecom
is only growing
econ sales are going to reach 700 800
billion this year right in the us
when you take a look at all that what
you realize is that there is a
phenomenal amount of opportunity but the
thing to understand is
who you're selling to and why what gary
talks about a lot and we talk about
meetings as well
is around content understanding your
audience and be able to produce content
and creating an environment for them
that's real and legitimate for that
audience and i think that's really the
key when we're talking about niche
i'm of the personal opinion we get a lot
of these questions on twitter and
whatnot about drop shipping
i'm not big on drop shipping myself i
prefer products that have
some meaning some category you're
building it for purpose real quick
real quick i'm sorry to interrupt zubin
i i think zubin is right in the macro
but i will say this because i think
you're you know assuming you're you're
in a new world where your words carry a
ton of weight
so the hedge is super important i know
exactly why you said drop shipping
you're not in love with because you're
because you're thinking chess i think
you'd probably agree with me that if
you're a kid with 850 bucks
doing a little bit of drop skipping is a
crazy learning curve right like
right like right i just wanted to make
sure because i know who's listening and
how
and i know like um
absolutely like to to your point matt
right matt if you want to spend a little
bit of money you want to learn the
business drop shipping is a great way to
do it right what i'm getting at is we're
talking about scaling businesses and
whatnot and yeah i looked into that and
um like the thing with it is you can't
have like control over shipping
or customer service and you're
completely from china
you're completely vulnerable matt but
when you have 900 bucks
real and you really want to be ecommerce
the alternative is really flip life
like get but i just want people to get
reps like i'm not even
like i'm not scared of anybody losing
all their money i think
trying to learn how to buy something and
sell it and the process of
is [ __ ] huge it just helps you so
much
i believe the reason that vaynerx you
know the company that holds vaynermedia
holds vaynercommerce is gonna win the
whole thing is
i'm blindly consumer-centric
all i care about is the consumer i don't
care about all the boardroom stuff
or the debates or the philosophy or the
harvard business school or the reports
or debating
it's i'm real life and the way the way
up
and the reason i'm good at real life is
because i do it
matt you know one of the things i i
learned early on um
when my father was selling stuff uh in
the newspaper and classifieds and
whatever there was a limited space
so every time he'd have to figure out
new ways
to say more cut the stuff etc and just
watching that you learn
so much from it to gary's all about
those reps you get those reps in
you get better at it so however you can
get those reps in
now at 17 i would do the econ business
about the number one thing you're into
because it's then more fun and you'll
have more energy to do it
than trying to [ __ ] thread the needle
on the perfect white space that
it's [ __ ] 20 20 everything's being
done nobody's inventing [ __ ]
the white space is are you [ __ ]
better than somebody
yeah matt great to have you man thank
you thank you
it's fun let's keep going hey gary hey
zubin
my name is i'm 15 years old and my
question is how to be a
first mover in audio thought and virtual
reality platform that you like guys say
that
audio is going to be the next big boom
for you ahmad uh i would say it is to
make
content on twitter and linkedin
specifically but other places
talking about your interest and
curiosity in it
and you doing a lot of educating you
know i talk a lot about
i [ __ ] on school a lot but i educate
myself heavy i read
thousands of hours worth of baseball
card information in the 80s
i read tens of thousands of hours
of information in the wine spectator
and the wine business when the internet
came along i was on message boards
24 7 learning learning learning the way
you'll be a first
mover is to be part of the community the
way to be a part of the community
is to write and make videos about it but
not
acting like an expert acting like a part
of the community questions curiosities
answering people's questions as you
become more educated
become part of the community that you
want to be a first mover in
and what that means is you bring value
and you extract learnings and that's the
game for me
zubin yeah i mean gary's the master at
this right the only thing i'll comment
on is vr
and the fact that certain technologies
like vr require additional hardware that
many people don't have
so i would take a step back from vr and
say okay what else
is there in that space that'll
eventually lead to vr potentially ar
look at stuff like that the technology
that you can actually leverage
on the devices that people own right now
100 and and and you're you're 15
as you might have seen from me before vr
scares me because i have vcs who want to
put 10 million
into a company today that needs to win
next year and i'm like it's not going to
happen but at 15
if you want to be the guy for vr there's
a good chance by the time you're 29
36 things popping off what you don't
know at 15 is that 29 and 36 is an
extremely young man
so putting in real work and being part
of that world is a big deal and a huge
opportunity if you're fascinated by it
thanks thank you my friend
what's good brian hey what's good gary
what's up zuvim
what's up buddy hey thanks for having me
i really appreciate it uh gary before i
jump into my question i have to tell you
this story because i might not ever get
a chance again
you know you held a zoom call on sports
cards about a month ago
yes um and like halfway through somebody
uh hacked the chat apparently it was
like sending up scene messages and stuff
yes i remember
yeah and they hacked it and um then i
saw my name up there with the messages
going by i'm like oh no what's going on
and then for a second uh gary is like um
really brian daley wasn't bringing value
to this chat yes i remember bro
and and by the way i did see you be like
that's not me i did catch that on my
right
i love that that's great bro you did you
save that clip that would just be epic
yeah i wish i could i wish i had
recorded it man i don't know if somebody
edited it
you know what you know what i know
somebody uh dustin i'm sure
dustin are you here behind producing
dustin find out from the team if we
recorded that i think we did
let's chop up the part and send it to
brian yeah
on youtube okay cool i appreciate that
yeah
that was a funny moment so i'm just glad
that i actually came full circle and
actually got it got to talk to you
all right so my question is um i have a
product that's a fairly unique
kind of niche we make granola bars using
uh spent grain from local craft
breweries
um so you know using the repurposing
upcycle angle
um and it's kind of like it appeals to
different segments the the people that
are uh health conscious the people that
care about sustainability and people
that like craft beer too
and sometimes those intersections kind
of conflict so that i have a lot of um
people that like the product or the hook
is the beer or the the beer aspect of it
but
they want to know if it has been or if
it's good for their kids kind of thing
so i mean it is it's all good it's not
in conflict
you just have to communicate on multiple
fronts i communicate
as a friend i communicate as a wine guy
i communicate as
a sports card a commentator i
communicate as a businessman
an operator uh you know i communicate in
a lot of lanes
people for some reason think multiple
stories conflict i think they add on
okay i think it's a thesis i think it's
a philosophy
you don't want to mix your message it's
[ __ ] you hear from b-school people
that are making complete judgment based
on non-practicality and based on a
television world
where we're really talking about a
commercial and pushing it down
we are now consumer up not tv down
and so i don't think why does it
conflict and you know some people might
care about two of the three
some may care about one of the three and
i don't see the confliction i really
don't and this is a debate i have with a
lot of people
brian what you might be seeing is you're
saying okay look i've got a site i've
got my social
what do i talk about what do i lead with
what do i do secondarily
all of it yeah all of it and then what
you do is
we talk about this frequently but build
landing pages for each of those segments
drive traffic to those and figure out
which one is actually meaningful for you
in the long term
because the other problem too is for so
long brands were focused on just that
initial sell
that they weren't thinking of customers
that actually love them and are going to
buy their products often or going to
tell other people about them
that's the game now forget about selling
your product at
whatever low return high return ad spend
low cap you're looking at
find those groups as you mentioned that
are going to love your product talk
about it and you can actually build an
entire company around them
gotcha 100 like
the notice what zubin said about the
landing pages
companies and thus a lot of the
education
still act as if the internet doesn't
exist
right i had to make a choice when you
walked into my pops liquor store
what the first display was going to be
yeah yeah and you know and i
but with your website to zoom in support
you have three separate landing pages
and when you make beer content
the url can point to the beer landing
page they don't even walk in their front
door anymore you just put them into an
aisle
right exactly that's perfect let's move
it
all right i'm glad we connected well
yeah man appreciate it
thanks before we get the next person big
shout out to jacob my sack thank you for
saying that eric dyer thanks for a nice
comment
i see all of you melissa lee what's good
i see all of you
megan elon let's keep it going
hey zubin gary how you doing good to see
you again gary great to see you dustin i
brought a friend
i brought a friend just in case a
beautiful friend
pistol pete baby hey um kind of a big
picture
question but um you know and maybe this
is a little bit extreme but
10 15 years down the road just from what
we've seen
during the pandemic but also pre
pandemic where you see amazon taking
over the world as far as
online retail and you guys are big you
know big guys in e-commerce
in 10-15 years are we gonna walk into a
brick-and-mortar retail store anymore
are people going to go to
office space you know or is it going to
kind of all move remotely
you know what are you going to see for
retail moving forward down the line
i i actually am chomping at the bit to
open a physical retail business
interesting yeah i think i think people
grossly underestimate
how long things take i've learned this
this is from experience i launched an
ecommerce wine business in 1996.
i said by the year 2000
everybody's going to know the this is by
the way this is a sneaky
mistake that turned into an incredible
advantage in building my dad's business
i said
in the year 2000 this is why i
understand that kids are impatient
because in 1996 when you're 21
four years from now there's like a high
percentage of your life
you know that's like 20 of my life that
seemed like a long time
in year 2000 if the y2k button doesn't
destroy us
everybody's going to walk into every
store in the country
and know the price of everything i
already kind of had a hunch of
smartphones i was like your phone
this is embarrassing to say i was like
people gonna buy a plug-in
for a scanner and they're gonna be able
to scan the upc of any item and the
phone is gonna tell you i mean this is
like where my head was at
and um so what i did was i literally had
a developer run a script for me scraping
the 55 websites there was only 55
other wine stores in 1997 when i had
this hypothesis
and there was one big website wine
access and we scraped it
and i knew the prices of every wine in
the country and i would update it
once a week and i would lower my prices
in my dad's store
and then a site by this name of wine
dasher came out
and did it mapped it for the industry
and i would price
every wine by a penny less minimally
than everybody else and became the cost
leader
because i had this great fear that by
the year 2000
everybody would know the price of
everything right and so what ended up
happening was
i learned how to run a business by
having such low margin on 5 000 popular
items and then figured that business out
which was great
and it also taught me the lesson of what
you're asking right now
there will be an ungodly amount of
stores in 15 years
they may be more experiential they may
offer different value props
but they will be there and two quick
takes for you
one gary talking about scraping
reminding me when i was a kid when i was
15 years old
i did what gary hired that guy to do for
a muffler
shop a set of muffler shops in uh in
illinois and i would go through
every single day and scrape the prices
of both of their
competitors as well as the distributors
and find out who they should buy from
every day so that was my job
um second thought amazon's obviously the
number one
uh online retailer in the us you know
what number two is
shopify you combine all of the shopify
store revenues they are number two wow
why does that matter as it relates to
your question
because what's happening is the move to
e-commerce is shifting to local stores
and so local stores are now selling
their products online
and partnering with like local delivery
uh
logistics companies they can actually
deliver the product for them or somebody
buys it online they go pick it up
curbside so the retail experience is
gonna shift and it's gonna change
but we all are gonna continue seeing
each other in person buying transacting
in person
i think it's just gonna evolve but
offices are gonna change for example i'm
locked into my lease pretty aggressively
but i was like you know what
i would probably buy a storefront right
now
mr storefront for vaynermedia
x probably i would probably have a
storefront on madison avenue
times square or something else i would
fit like 50 to 100 people
in the office they would literally come
in they would rotate but i would
create some sort of front-facing thing
for just by accident
customers or relationships or to have
clients have a coffee there
like have a bar or coffee like i i can
see a lot of offices
going to the first floor creating a
front-facing coffee shop
or bar for culture and then on the back
have 50 seats even though they used to
have 200
so that they are going to be able to do
a rotation
and create front-facing by accident
awareness and culture i mean
i've been thinking a lot about it i i
think it's a really cool innovation
cool so more of a branding play kind of
with that with the branding awareness
stuff
even if you're b2b why not if you're a
law firm and you've got 67 lawyers
in a ninth floor of an office building
the world's changing now
real estate is collapsing storefronts
collapsing why not
make it get a storefront now
have third people come in rotate that's
the seats open desk hot desk but they
have a receptionist a little coffee
maybe do consultation maybe do content i
was also thinking oh i would put
a studio in front kind of like the tv
networks do and you can see i'm just
maybe i'm filming all my content we
could be filming commercials for clients
right on times square as an agency
that's kind of cool that's different
maybe that space is something as a
billboard people are going to start
listen
i'm a [ __ ] innovator and and the
reason i
make a lot of predictions properly is
because i know what i would do
i'm not going to get around to what i
just said but i'm hoping somebody just
heard that and says wait a minute that's
cool i'm gonna do it like
like and i also know i'm not the only
one not so special there are plenty of
other people
that see around corners or see i always
think about life as
remember that thing we were taught as
kids like is it two people kissing or is
it a champagne flute
yeah people see different [ __ ]
everyone's everyone sees the obvious of
like
oh we're never gonna [ __ ] the office and
we're not gonna stores i'm like
evolution yeah no that's great stuff i
appreciate it guys
cheers have you on
gabrielle
hey dustin can you get gabrielle proper
maybe go to the next one and get the
next person proper
brad that's good
very good my friend how are you yeah i'm
great thanks uh
my question it's not like an econ
question but they still said come on and
ask more questions
so basically i'm 21 years old and ever
since i was 16
i basically weren't getting jobs a dead
end job
basically trying to find a passion as
you could say
but like i always seem to try something
and think oh this is the one
and completely switch around and get
bored of it and i just want to find like
my passion
i just don't know like how to go about
it because
i constantly think like ah i've found it
but like i haven't if you know what i
mean i do know what you mean
have you ever really gave a lot of
thought to what you do
when you're not working like as a human
being music food
friends you know have you how much have
you
like what do you do for hobbies or how
do you
spend or waste your time say why split
on others
well i mean i think we all spend and
waste time and sometimes
the way you waste your time is the
insight you love
video games that's how you're
quote-unquote wasting your time flip it
and that's how
your life is going to change you waste
your time watching
netflix all day well maybe you just like
content a lot
and maybe either you start a podcast of
judging content because you like doing
it all day or maybe actually it's an
insight to you being a creator of
content
i think people very much struggle
finding their passion because they don't
think the
love are practical they've been taught
that that's not how you can make money
yeah yeah definitely
anytime you start a sentence with
everybody else you're already in deep
[ __ ] that is the single reason
you're feeling pressure i don't give a
[ __ ] of all
19 of your 21 year old best friends
become mark [ __ ] zuckerberg and elon
musk
it has nothing to do with you
they're getting on with it you think you
don't know if they're crying in their
bedroom
you have no idea what they're getting on
with the fact that you're spending time
worrying that they're on their way and
you're not is going to lead you into a
hole
of never getting out of it yeah
comparison is a devastating thing brad
it's a it doesn't it's devastating
absolutely i think that's like where a
lot of the pressure comes from because
like
i'm constantly very caring instead of
realizing that
you know everyone's in their own path in
life and i'm
immediately mate i was i was
working i was a cashier at 21 years old
in a liquor store
i wasn't getting on with [ __ ] or
i was getting on with everything you
know what i mean like it all is
perspective
let me give you one really good piece of
advice start by
enjoying the [ __ ] out of being 21
because
notice how zoom just reacted just being
21 is [ __ ] winning in life
look again uh gary's given you amazing
advice all i can say
is that you're trying to figure out that
one passion
right now and go this is it and i'm
gonna move on why not just enjoy the
fact that you're hopping from one thing
to another trying to figure out what
your passion is
you're going to look back in 10 years 5
years 10 years 15 years and go [ __ ] i
wish i was 21 trying to figure my [ __ ]
out
and i wish i did more and i wish i spent
more time
figuring it out than pursuing one in my
mind you're doing much better than most
people your age
mostly your mates because they they're
going down one path
you're jumping around until you find
that path the question brad is
is whose judgment on you are you
accepting
yeah the real question here is whose
words
are dictating your anxiety you know is
it your mom your dad your older brother
and sister
your best friend your girl your boy like
who's [ __ ] you
up with them imposing their insecurities
on you
and you taking them on anybody that
tells you you should have your life
together at 21 is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and if that's your mom put her on screen
right now and tell her right to her
[ __ ] face like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] bro yeah
well absolutely now i want you to live
it you need to pay attention to who's
talking to you and who you're listening
to
and brad no one's gonna figure it out
man we're all still trying to figure it
out
i got it brad i got it figured out let
me give you the answer
i'm kidding but i got that let me tell
you this
i don't have it figured out i have this
one figured out
to think that you have to have your [ __ ]
figured out at 21
is [ __ ] insane
point the fact you're tasting all these
things that's what's interesting to me
do more side jobs you might be the
greatest cook in the world you have no
idea
go work in a [ __ ] restaurant like
take risks this is when it's practical
enjoy brad smile
and you have a great [ __ ] smile brad
he's right like what you need to do is
make sure that you have positivity and
optimism and patience
like i call it pop right positivity
optimism and patience in your ear
over and over and over that's how you
win your 20s
bro 30 years old is a [ __ ] child
a child
absolutely yeah all right thanks there
anyway cheers
all right i gotta bounce uh and you've
only got three minutes and i know
we want to help out somebody we're
working with so let's uh let's do that
[ __ ]
that was awesome comments are epic oh
that's what's wrong
um i mean there was a video submission i
don't know if you want to
do that one we're not gonna be able to
sneak it in because zombies got i want
to make sure
i'll contact that person directly okay
okay yeah this was amazing i absolutely
love this thanks for uh
scary uh quick shout out to our
client bodybuilding that is doing a lot
of amazing things
they're growing um and they're looking
to hire in a number of positions
product designer senior product manager
lifestyle marketing manager
uh software developers etc i know we've
got an amazing group of people listening
in
tuning in so if you're interested go to
jobs.bodybuilding.com
apply make sure you mention gary and me
and
best of luck to you to the rest of you
thank you so much for tuning in today i
hope it was uh
it was as beneficial for you as it was
for me
i really enjoyed it i hope you enjoyed
it as well and i look forward to seeing
you all
uh on the next episode of coffee and
commerce